absolutely love these pillars hey also
guys my name is Luciano and welcome back
to myself life series so today we're
back on the couch you guys seem to dig
that didn't have much time to go
anywhere exciting for this video however
the content is going to make up for that
because today we're going to be learning
all about how to use Visual Studio to
debug our code now in planning this
series unfortunately I have the
difficult decision I was trying to
decide which video goes where in what
order and all that stuff
a lot of these videos kind of depend on
each other so if you see me mention
things in certain videos that I haven't
mentioned in previous videos it doesn't
mean that I've kind of glossed over the
topic it just means that it's probably
going to come later that being said
though debugging is just such an
important part of programming and not
just programming but of learning because
if you know how to debug your code
you're actually going to understand how
the program works and how the computer
actually runs your code so I thought I'd
cover debugging pretty early on in this
series because I'm actually going to use
a lot of what we cover today to explain
how the rest is language and how
computer programs work in general in
this video specifically like all of my
support videos I'm going to be using
Visual Studio however this concept
applies to pretty much any IDE out there
most ideas will support exactly what I'm
going to show here today just might be
in a different place but basically we're
going to be covering two important
features for free is a three I don't
even know how Matt we can probably break
this thing is to find breakpoints see
that joke earlier was funny because
breakpoints is a big part of debugging
and looking at memory the breakpoints
and reading memory those are kind of the
two big parts of debugging it and of
course you will be using them together
so in other words you'll set breakpoints
in order to read memory so what's the
point of debugging what do I mean when I
say let's debug our code the word debug
means to debug right so to remove bugs
from our code in order to remove a bug
from our code we have to diagnose what
with our program and that part can
actually be pretty tricky even if you're
well experienced in the language at the
end of the day you have to remember that
the computer is always right and by
always I mean like 99% of the time it's
very unlikely that you did something
correctly and then the computer just
didn't work as expected it's usually
it's usually you who made a mistake and
coming to realize that it's something
that is very important for programmers
you will soon learn that the computer is
pretty much always right so really this
is all about figuring out your mistake
what did I do wrong
what did I do to deserve this so
breakpoints reading memory let's take a
look so here I have a pretty simple
visual studio project I've got my main
file here which calls logs is the log
CBP and logs are age that we made in the
previous video in the video about C++
header files what we're going to do
first of all is we're going to set a
breakpoint and then we're going to step
through the execution of our program so
what our break point so a breakpoint is
a point in our program at which the
debugger will break and the word break
here just means pause so what will
happen is we can basically set a
breakpoint on any line of code in our
program and when when the execution hits
that line it will pause it will suspend
that execution thread on our case the
entire program and let us take a look at
the state of this program and by state
I'm really referring to memory we can
pause our program and just take a look
at what is going on in its memory
remember the memory of a running program
is pretty much all it's got it's what
every variable is set to it's what
function will be called max everything
when you will you break it down memory
is all older there is really so being
able to view memory is incredibly useful
in diagnosing what the issue is with
your program because by viewing the
memory you can see what every variable
is set to and be like hey this variable
shouldn't be set to this value
something's obviously wrong you can also
step through the execution of your
program line by line so I can put a
breakpoint on line five and then just
just hit a button and the program will
advance just one line of code further
into line six you can also step into
functions to see where they'll take you
it's just just so much you can do with
breakpoints it's amazing
and it's incredibly useful and if you're
programming without this then I don't
even know what you're doing so back to
Moodle studio in order to set a
breakpoint individual to you you can
either just hit f9 and it will set a
breakpoint on that car line of code or
you can click on this sidebar anywhere
under side by here just click once and
you'll set a breakpoint obviously if you
do something like set a breakpoint on
line 3 that's not really going to work
because there's nothing on line 3 is
ever going to get executed so make sure
you set a breakpoint on cones that
actually will be executed on lines that
will actually be hit so line 6 of course
will be here because that's the first
line of code in our program and then all
you have to do is run your code through
the debugger one tip is to make sure
that you're in debug mode because if
you're in release mode the compiler will
actually change the way that your code
look and your breakpoints might not ever
get hit because your program has been
rearranged we'll talk more in depth
about what release mode actually does
and all that stuff later but the gist is
if your debugging just make sure you're
in debug mode if we then hit the local
windows debugger which ensures that
we're actually running with the debugger
attached our program will run and you
can see that the focus from our program
is actually stolen back to visual studio
and we change into this kind of
different alternate layout along with a
big yellow arrow on that breakpoint
indicating that that is currently where
the instruction pointer is at in our
program the main areas to look at here
are basically this continue button which
will continue executing our program like
normal and then we have a bunch of
buttons over here to let us step in to
step over or step out now these three
buttons are going to control exactly
what happens next in our program so step
into is going to step into the current
function that is on this line of code if
there is a function so in this case if I
have stepped into an to log we would
actually step into the log function so
that we could see what it does step over
is going to step over to the next line
of code in this current function and
step out is actually going to step out
of this current function and take us
back to whatever call of this function
which in this case is if this is the
main function will be the C standard
library you can also use f11 to step
into f10 step over or shift at 11 to
step out so let's step into this log
function and see what happens I'm going
to hit
eleven okay check this out so we step
into this function we're at the very
beginning of the SAP frame we haven't
actually begun executing any code here
we're just setting up this function
stack frame we can hover our mouse over
this message variable and check us out
it tells us that it's set to hello world
so that's the second part of debugging
right we're reading memory now how cool
is this
if I hit f10 is going to bring us up to
this line of code now the fact that the
yellow arrow is on this line of code
means that it actually hasn't executed
this line of code yet it's just it's on
there it's about true as soon as we hit
a button like a scan or shift f11 to get
out of the function or f5 which will
continue our program as soon as we hit
one of those is going to execute that
line of code and possibly more but the
yellow arrow means that it is on that
line of code it hasn't actually executed
that line of code yet so if I bring up
my program right now you can see that
that hello world message has not been
printed but check this out if I hit at
can and then check back look at that
we've printed hello world because we've
called that STD see our function and it
actually has printed that text to the
console we've executed that function so
by setting breakpoints and by stepping
through our program we can literally run
our entire program line by line which of
course is really cool and really useful
when you're trying to figure out what
you've done wrong anyway back here if we
keep hitting f10 you'll see that we'll
eventually get back to our main function
f10 again we'll bring up to the next
line of code in our main function and
this will kind of keep going
if I hit f5 is going to continue running
our program as usual and I can just get
an to it to propose my program as if it
was just running normal alright it's a
pretty cool stuff and even though this
might look really simple this is
actually really all there is to it I
mean I've shown you guys pretty much
everything I'll show you some more
example so that you really get it but
that's kind of the gist of it so let's
go ahead and make some more variable to
make things interesting I'm going to
make an integer called a set it equal to
8 I'm going to do a plus plus which will
increment a by 1 so in other words it
will set a to be 9 I'm going to create a
c string here by just typing in college
our string equals hello i'm going to
write a very basic for loop here that's
going to iterate through the string and
print each character out on a separate
and then I'll leave in my log hello
world for good measure so if I run my
program with our breakpoints at all just
to see what even happens you'll see that
we get basically something like this
where we have hello and then hello world
all right now I step through this line
by line and when I set a breakpoint at
the very top here on a and just hit f5
all right cool let's take a look what a
is what why is it negative 858 million
well remember that yellow arrow doesn't
mean that we've actually run this code
we're actually just about to run it but
we haven't actually executed line six
the one that actually creates and sets
that a variable so what the debugger is
currently showing us is what the memory
where a would be is showing right now
and since we haven't actually set that
variable to anything yet
it's just uninitialized memory which
means that this value is just showing up
whatever that memory actually contains
this would be a fantastic time to bring
up these three important windows that we
have here Otto's locals and wash orders
and locals will basically just try and
show you
local variables or variables that it
thinks might be important to you watch
on the other hand lets us actually
monitor variables so what I can do is I
can type in a which is the name of the
variable and here enter and you can see
that it's showing in the value of a if I
also want to view what string is I can
also put that in and it's going to show
me what string is now of course we have
an initialize this memory yet so it's
currently as completely useless it's
just garbage but as we step through our
program these values will update to show
what's actually in the memory speaking
of memory there's actually a view that
we can use to view the entire memory of
our program now of course it's called a
memory of you so if we don't debug
windows memory and memory one we're
going to be greeted by this weird-lookin
panel here that's going to show all of
the memory of our program so on the very
left we see the memory addresses in the
middle we see the actual data the actual
values represented in hexadecimal format
and on the right we see the ascii
interpretation of those numbers if you
want to locate where does a variable
actually installed as a memory of your
program you need to know its memory
address and to do that we can simply
type in ampersand and a so the ampersand
in front of the variable name will
actually get that bear
murmuring address if we hit enter we're
going to be taken to the memory address
of that a variable which in this case is
a whole bunch of C's so that number that
safety number is actually a hexadecimal
value if you want to see what that is in
decimal you can bring up a calculator if
we switch to the programmer view we can
type in two hexadecimal value if I just
click on hexadecimal here type in cc as
you can see what that value is in
decimals 204 so 204 CC why is it set to
that isn't that memory just supposed to
be random a whole bunch of safeties
seems kind of specific now that's the
cool thing about debug mode and also why
debug mode slowed down our program it's
because the compiler will actually make
our program do certain things certain
extra things it's going to make allies
easier when it comes to be bugging so
for example the fact that this memory is
a whole bunch of cc's means that it is
uninitialized staff memory so what
actually happened is the compiler knows
that we're making we're trying to make a
variable but we haven't initialized it
yet so what I'm going to do is actually
fill that memory with CC so that if
we're debugging our code and something
goes wrong we can look at the memory we
can see that it's set to CC and we can
be like oh of course
I never initialized that variable that's
why this is going all wrong now by doing
extra things like that like setting our
memory to CC before we initialize it
obviously our program is doing extra
things that are going to slow it down so
we don't want to be doing that in
release mode when we actually release
our program when we ship our game we
want to be doing all that but when it
comes to debugging is very useful so if
I come over here and I hit ask and a lot
of things are going to happen one other
thing you can do actually in this watch
window is right click and select
hexadecimal display and so now you can
see that the value of a actually is a
whole bunch of C's which of course means
that a is currently on an initialized
stack memory let's go back to our
non-tax decimal display and let's hit
f10 and a number of cool things are
going to happen so namely in this watch
window our value has changed to a it's
also red which indicates that it's
changed since the last breakpoint our
instruction pointer has moved down which
is showing that it's now about about tax
if you're defining code hasn't done it
yet no no not yet but it's about two
and then if we look in our memory view
you can also see that these four bytes
of memory has been set to eight by the
way I should probably mention that every
two digits here is equal to one byte
that's also why web viewing is in
hexadecimal because if we do that every
two hexadecimal digits are always going
to align to be one byte of memory so we
can tell just by looking at this that
these eight hexadecimal digits are four
bytes of memory and you can see that
it's been set to eight so that's what
we're doing that's all we're doing right
now we've paused our program and we're
taking a look at its state we're reading
its memory
if I hit f10 again we're going to
advance this is now set to nine it's
such nine here as well pretty cool stuff
you can see that string is still
uninitialized stack memory but check
this out I'm about to initialize in
honor so if I hit f10 it's initialized
because this is an actual pointer it's
also telling us the memory address of
that string so if I was to copy this
memory address here from the what window
and paste it into my memory view and hit
enter look at this I'm taking to these
bytes which in this ask interpretation
you can see that it says hello and
what's really interesting is that if you
actually keep reading you can see that
our program literally contains memory
close to this hello variable that says
stack around a variable was corrupted
the variable is being used without being
initialized obviously our program
containing strings like stack around the
variable was corrupted in its memory is
not something that will exist in release
mode but it's just another great example
of what will actually happen in debug
mode to help you debug the program okay
cool so things getting real interesting
here because we've run into this for
loop what's going to happen if I keep
advancing through this now we haven't
covered for loops or any kind of control
flow statements in this series yet the
next few videos are probably going to
deal with it I really wanted to cover
the debugger first so that we can
actually step through this control flow
statements in the future and see how
they work and you guys already know how
to use this debugger view but basically
of all it's going to do stuff multiple
times so if we step through this program
you can see that is set to zero it's
going to grab index 0 from this string
which is going to be the very first
character in the string
which is a capital H if we hit f10 we
can hover our mouse over C and see
there's a set to H we can also come over
here into watch and just type in C and
you can see when our taking a look at
what C is when I hit f10 is going to log
that letter to the console and then when
it gets back to this curly bracket it's
going to run this comparison it's going
to compare is I less than 5 and then if
so it's going to increment I and then
jump back into here so if I hit f10 you
can see we jump up here to do the
comparison if I hit f10 again we've done
the I plus plus I is now 1 we're going
to do the same thing all over again
except this time I is 1 so it's going to
grab the second character which is the
letter E and continue on in this case C
is equal to e you consider this change
here you know watch if we come up here
do ampersand C and hit enter you can see
we have 65 which is the letter e
according to our asked of you fantastic
I can keep running through this and
everything's going to be great now
suppose that I wanted to answer this for
loop and maybe jump to this log function
I don't really care about stepping
through this I get how it works
how do I get out of this for loop if I
try and step out or hit shift at 11 it's
actually going to enter the whole
function I don't want to do that I just
want to kind of keep running the for
loop and then stop here how do I do that
well it's pretty simple all you have to
do is put a breakpoint on where you want
to stop next and if I hit f5 or press
the continue button up here it's
actually going to run my program until
it hears the next breakpoint which in
this case is this log function so by
this point he considers the memory that
used to make up this C variable is set
to o it's actually still active that
memory still there even though we've
gone out of scope and we'll talk about
that in the future but the memory of
sets the very last character the word
hello if we bring back our program you
can see it's printed up that entire
hello word and then we're about to
execute this hello world log by hit f10
we're going to jump to the next line of
code here it's going to print hello
world now we've actually paused
execution of this program because we had
a breakpoint here I just hit f10 so if I
press ENTER here nothing is actually
going to happen I need to hit f5 and
then
our program will close because it is
going to still detect that Enterprise so
that's it a fantastically simple
overview of basic debugging that's going
to be a lot more through this but what I
just showed in this video is going to be
the basis of how we actually debug our
code remember a program is really just
made up of memory even the instruction
pointer which is where in our program we
actually are executing code and the
actual code that we're executing all of
that is stored in memory so being able
to view our memory is really all we have
and really all we need and by setting
breakpoints it lets us pause our program
at a given time at a given line of code
and actually inspect it and take a look
to see what all of our variables are set
to which of course is going to be
incredibly useful when you're running
code
I hope you guys enjoyed this video if
you did please hit that like button
let's see if we can beat our like record
I don't know I think it's about 800
let's just let's just let's just smash
that you can follow me on Twitter and
Instagram I've been posting some pretty
cool photos on Instagram lately so you
just get you're just not going to want
to miss that at all and if you really
like this series you can support me on
patreon comm forth that's the channel
now the cool thing about this is by
doing so you'll get access to early
drafts of videos and the cool thing
about those early drafts is not
everything in the draft makes it to the
final video to this so you get see stuff
that might be cut from the final video
exclusive and as well as that of course
you are supporting this series and
you're enabling me to make more of these
videos more often which is pretty
awesome hope you guys have a great day
I'll see you in the next video goodbye
[Music]
[Music]